well I'd always dreamed of having my
son's down his movies because I love to
write stories and so we took the idea to
Netflix and they fell for it and they
not only fell for it they kind of got
behind it and so here we are with
heartstrings and really it's kind of
hopefully my songs or things that kind
of tug at your heartstrings and I just
hope people are gonna love it
I introduced all of them and I do
starring some of them and then I do bits
and pieces in some of them but I'm not
starring in all of them
which one is a variety one about a dog
and of course we did two doors down and
we had a fun show about that and Jolene
so we just picked the ones that we
thought would make good stories I was so
honored when I got the call literally
from Dolly Parton herself and Sam
Haskell her producing partner when they
asked me to be Jolene I just was like I
already had a project that I was
supposed to be doing and I was like and
that is cancelled and I will do anything
to work with Dolly and also to play such
an iconic role that has meant so much to
so many people's lives working with
dolly is incredible I mean she has so
much wisdom she's been in this industry
for I don't even know how long but she
she has been this little this little
lady with like this big voice and this
this you know big message to share with
the world and she's never stopped you
know and she's always believed in
herself so for for her to be able to
share that with me as an actress but
also the character it was amazing